jetzt habe ich habe dass ich tief mit
diamonds empfehlen dass im chat herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge von
minecraft war nach dieser folge werden
wir uns doch ein wenig ausnutzen ganz
innovativ wir haben uns gedacht dass es
doch gar nicht mal so und sinnvoll wäre
jetzt noch weiter hier an dieser stelle
zu verbleiben und ärzte einzusammeln
wir hatten kein eisen mehr oder das
heißt ich brauche neues eisenach
eisenach gibt und wenn ich mal eine
eisen spitzhacke neue und vielleicht
kommt ja noch mal dass diamanten klick
auf bild de der unglaublich schön wenn
wir ja mal diamanten kriegen dass das
wäre das wäre obwohl dieses ja etwas so
ein bisschen weiter je nach ärzten und
danach wollten wir dann auch eventuell
mal umziehen weil jetzt könnt ihr das
ein paar schlawiner unter euch unsere
koordinaten verraten werden natürlich
nicht so geil wenn er irgendwann bei uns
auf einmal der tür leute leute die leute
was ich auch noch erwähnen wollte
wir haben tatsächlich wir waren wir
waren unserem glück so unsicher dass wir
dann auch noch nachgefragt haben ob
irgendwie die map so gemordet ist das
mehr diamanten existieren oder sowas
aber pustekuchen
wir sind einfach nur krass dass andere
leute haben das nicht weil da gehe ich
jetzt bin ich hin
andere leute also
wenige leute bisher diamanten bzw so
viel wie wir das ist echt krass würde
ich sagen
vor allem weil einfach reif und
krankhafter mit mir kontakt mit denen
manchmal einfach so geht also sagen was
sie schon haben wir schlagen die
inzwischen durch 36 mit kran krieg
kennen das ist tabu erkennen kleine
minister plural von jojo weiss ich nehme
es einfach mal es damit vielleicht macht
man ja irgendwann mal fallen was ich
jetzt endlich mal erwähnen muss so jetzt
fällt mir noch in der folge ein und zwar
dieses inselteile wunderschöne intro das
hier immer bei meinen minecraft bahro
episoden sieht er säte das hat der
ranger center gemacht unten link zu
diesem intro und seinem kanal befindet
sich in meiner beschreibung das würde
mich tierisch freuen wenn ihr bei seiner
hochgeladen version des intros vorbei
schauen uns einfach auf der linken und
auch eine positive bewertung da last
damit er so ein bisschen was für seine
sehr spontane und schnelle arbeit
ausländer das logo gemacht und so bei
mir deswegen seite einfach ein bisschen
bisschen freundlich und friedlich und
danach könnt ihr auch gerne masturbieren
das ist gar kein problem das machte gar
nicht interhome das mache ich auch immer
wenn ich sein interessiert irgendwann
muss haben sind übrigens auch ein video
gemacht
wir haben ein bisschen versucht zu
erklären ich höre was sie möchten wasser
versucht ein bisschen so auf euch da
zuzugehen und da so ein bisschen das zu
verstehen warum wir das nicht
geschrieben das versucht ein bisschen zu
erklären
das haben wir wenn ihr diese folge seht
vor zwei tagen hochgeladen
könnt ihr euch noch mal anschauen weil
es immer noch leute hier meckern ich
habe eine schöne links gefunden das hat
eine höhle gefunden wo alle möglichen
ärzte sind nein das hat das studium
komplett kann nicht wahr sein das ist
nicht zu fassen jetzt auch ob sie buback
nicht sinnlos mit dem mit dem judo da
wird noch richtig zum zum zum minecraft
profi der spitzbube ich habe ein
bisschen angst an der lavadom ihre yalda
zukauf sichert gewundert
du hast nicht diamanten von alder das
war war
aber alter weise wie viel das ich gerade
einfach eiskalt ab achtung es sind sechs
stück schon wieder ab es kann nicht sein
es ist nicht wahr ich finde hier nur
eisen und bleiben so und jetzt ja eisen
ist ja gut weil wir müssen uns ja auch
mal irgendwann verzauberung tisch machen
und das haben ein bisschen
überdramatisiert in einer der folgen
dass das multimedia aufwendige was ja
gar nicht so ist ja wir brauchen ja
obsidian das können wir uns ja machen
mit wasser und lava oder ein link sie
ich habe hier übrigens ganz viel
obsidian in einer höhle hier unten wir
müssen das quasi nur abbauen
ja ich hab gerade auf reisen aber geht
obsidian nicht nur mit habe ich jetzt
geht das geht nur mit einer spitzhacke
ich kann es ja mal probieren mit also
neben ich glaube dass ihr seht top top
minecraft profi liga lfp mit allen es
geht nur mit dir sein natürlich auch
klar
logische hat es ausprobiert weil er
vielleicht dachte vielleicht ist ja
etwas hinterher statt worden
dort wurden im verlaufe der jahre jetzt
habe ich wieder sechster ist das ist
schön
übrigens war ich tatsächlich als ich
diese neuen diamanten gefunden habe ich
habe mich heute morgen an denen an den
mittagstisch gesetzt und ab sowohl von
mehreren familienmitgliedern zu
verbringen so neuen diamanten war denn
da los
ja habe ich mich sehr träume hat davon
geträumt
naja ich hab gut geträumt und
wahrscheinlich bin ich nachts durch
durch das ganze haus gewandert in das
alte männer in das elternschlafzimmer
das ende einer schlacht das schlafzimmer
meiner eltern rein
aber wir haben eine menge obsidian du ja
das ist gut aber ist es nicht so dass
wenn man lava und wasser zusammen tut
dass man dann cobblestone bekommt und
nicht obsidian ist drauf politisch
natürlich schießen jetzt habe ich mich
aber hier zurück gegraben quasi ist ja
auch okay so ich immer wieder nach omac
einfach und seien unter der erde
wieso die sind die sind ja die sind ja
ja es kann sein dass sie trotzdem bei
uns sind hol dir einfach mal bitte
ebenfalls mit den hier machen immer
irgendwie was zum anziehen oder so ja
ich mach dir oder so weg an den helm
machen ich habe mir helfen nach ihrem
letzten schuljahr ich kann ich keine
hose machen ich muss nur kurz den
rückweg finden hier so da geht es
natürlich nicht ich will jetzt nicht die
ganze zeit springen das dauert nämlich
ewig und wenn sie uns finden dann wären
sei aber abgeschlachtet ja da mama keine
kompromisse zwei ähnliche und der höhle
ich habe nächste mal ein bisschen rote
augen wegen einfach schlafmangel ja ja
ja ja obwohl ich revidieren möchte dass
ich in der letzten episode gesagt hat
dass ich ganz okay inzwischen pvp bin
ich habe in letzter zeit also wir haben
gestern trat bestätigen paar youtuber
gespielt und nicht auf dem server
sondern auch so einen gegner gespielt
und ich habe gemerkt ich gute bvb ganz
im gegenteil ich bin beschämt
schrenk möchte ich behaupten kinder ist
auf jeden fall noch ich mache das ja
dass auf jeden fall super toll hat so
event magath ganz kurz für unsere kleine
basis dar einen schlüpfen und mal ganz
kurz schauen ob du irgendwo die namen
liest weil ich es nicht gerade wieder
ein verrückter ich bin ich bin ich hier
in der basis aber ich kann auch mal kurz
raus gucken es nachts ist nicht nach ich
guck mal raus ok sneakers sind endermann
der school
ich finde einfach keine diamanten dass
unsere treffen ist wäre ich gucke ich
habe dafür ich hab ihm gehen ja simon
hat gene ich habe diamanten geben wie
ich sehe ich sehe keinen namen ich
glaube die sind in der anderen richtung
also geht's auch wieder zurück ja erst
langsam und der internet kommt glaube
ich in julie julia
ich gehe jetzt wieder nach oben hier und
ich sehe einen namen
was isst du zum glück holte spannende
ich mal lieber darum musste aber einem
angst ohne ende hier mal das einzige was
gefunden war ein bisschen also ein
bisschen kohle ja ich habe mal wieder
diamanten mitgebracht das ist ja ich
finde ich kümmere mich lieber mehr an
einem baum der nicht wächst deshalb auch
ein unterschied ob du jetzt profi bis
oder ich übrigens mal hier irgendwie
unseren eingang dicker zu dass wenn die
sich durchschlagen dass die brauchen
weiß dass ihr das hört oder so da steht
hier wieder wie viel denn jetzt ich hab
die studie macht bitteschön paar schuhe
es ist so schön dass wir schon so weit
sind
am besten lässt wenn wir irgendwie dann
noch einen bogen hätten oder so ja soll
ich soll ich jetzt aus den restlichen
die jahres eine eisen also eine
spitzhacke machen und das obsidian
abbauen gehen oder ja auch nicht falsch
ich habe hier so eine app ja das ist
jetzt zwar mega zeitverschwendung aber
ich hab mir als wenn wir das dann
irgendwie verschwenden oder so und da
kann ich jetzt mal nachgucken
ich habs nur vier prozent akku aber das
wird schon ausreichen und ich stehe
jetzt tatsächlich in minecraft war
stickig still rum und macht nix profi so
minecraft crafting guide guide gedöns
kram so ist es irgendwo das ist obsidian
oder ja und konnte nachrichten
ich hab das aktiviert ist der dritte
treffer nachrichten so ja nee also
obsidian aus obsidian alt eigentlich
oder oder ich war ich weiß nicht kann
man kann man das kann man das du du du
bist der minecraft kanal warum weißt du
nicht nur obsidian ja mit diamanten
gangart muss ich muss ich das ab nach
und nach abbauen gib mir das gibt mir
die sache jedenfalls aus hier sollen wir
mal weitere diamanten holen ja oh jetzt
hab ich hab das archiv mit diamonds wir
sehen das im chat ein bisschen jetzt
jetzt geht's weiter aber unvorsichtige
zwei euro kann man aber aufpassen wir
dürfen uns nicht so zu überschätzen hier
mit der jetzt scheiße wir sind immer
noch schlecht geht wenig vergessen
mutige haben irgendwo eigentlich noch
holz auf das was mitgebracht schön schön
ich hab's auch nicht rausgenommen pro
doch habe ich nein ich hab verschoben
ich bin das erde das kantholz ja erst
mal stark mal wieder deutscher profi
gameplay auch ein pass auf der obsidian
ab wie viel braucht mit der person
scheiß verzaubern
33 und dann muss ich noch mehr sachen
dass ihr netter gehen vielleicht können
dann musste ich ja mach mach mach mach
einfach boykottiert da irgendein thema
weil sonst ich will ehrlich nicht so
einfach rumstehen irgendein thema in
minecraft waro brauchst du keine themen
du brauchst lediglich den spirit ein
bisschen falsch angegangen ja eine sache
fehlt und so dass es einfach wirklich
ein bisschen unser mantra uns fehlen die
dreadlocks und uns fehlt wirklich die
entspannung und ein bisschen meditieren
und wirklich sich auch in das projekt
einfühlen
spüren konsequenten von graz konsum habe
ich schon in meinen augen das ist bei
mir zu hause schlafen sollen zwei wie
der penis deines partners in dich
eindringt dass das ist finde ich dass
wichtige in mancher brauche ich denn
insgesamt wartet fortpflanzung aber du
bist ein mal gucken ob da vielleicht
zwölf brauche ich insgesamt für so einen
scheiß verzaubern sachen verzauberung
tisch schon haben
soria tier 1 also ein bücherregal
chancen bücher müssen wir nochmal und
die machen wir aus papier er oben vogel
ist irgendwo so zucker war ja aber jetzt
bin ich gerade unten und bis auf den
jemand weiß weil wir brauchen ja noch
bauen ja noch einen weiteren diamanten
wir brauchen zwei und hat nur noch einen
oben ok jetzt gut aber ich finds straff
wie eine verzauberte der schwede amtiert
und sorgst du mal wenn ich einfach den
deal lp und den heutigen kopf kürzer
machen
ja du jetzt aber noch nicht nennen doch
einfach mal losgehen
ich wollte keine soll ich meine dass man
das meinen spaß ich dachte schon du
hältst gerade auf einmal bekommen alte
hng gut ist ich doch nicht erwachsen
überlebt kef die erste folge ich gesagt
dass ich für witzel draußen wieder zehn
obsidian nur noch zwei spiele haben wir
auf jeden fall des portals eines voraus
hat er hat schon die mann getötet das
haben wir nicht geschafft
wer da du hast nicht gerade riesig ich
hab keine tiere riesige schlucht
gefunden hätte lindsay fechterin rate
ich möchte auch mal was spiel im alter
ich dachte gar nicht werden ich bin aber
gefallen alter alles auf kinospaß
wirklich auf auch immer wieder dazu ich
will nicht die schlucht keinen bock
drauf dass auch wir haben hier noch
sachen das ist ein bisschen kraft weil
ich habe so was du stirbst danke du hast
also nur angst das okay okay okay du
wenn du dann auf die weise willst das
sage ich geguckt wie lange wir schon
aufnehmen oder wann wir angefangen haben
oder sogar zweieinhalb minuten aber wir
können bis 15 minuten locker aufnehmen
weil wir ja bis 17 minuten
rader grad genau weil wir waren bisher
immer also wir aber der ersten folge
sogar darunter
weil wir gedacht haben
und so lässt fahrer und balkonen
bisschen unter zeitdruck war und
deswegen sind wir da sind wir recht früh
raus gekoppelt aber ansonsten sind wir
immer immer punktlandung auf auffällige
zahl 15 millimeter ich finde hat nur
jetzt jetzt ist man also das wäre echt
bitter wenn ich jetzt keine die us markt
wo wir noch ein brauchen wir hätten uns
echt mal zwei noch aufheben sollen bevor
wir die diamanten schule gemacht hätten
wäre unnötig noch riesige lava floss es
täglich ich hab so babbel
ich habe genug aktien jobs ideal ist
cool dass youtube da ist jetzt brauchen
wir nur wo irland ich denn hier die
geht's hier raus oder wie das wäre ja
das war ja also ich glaube jetzt raus
ich habe die ganze das gefühl weißt du
nicht bauen blog weg und plötzlich steht
dario oder oder holly vor mir ja das
hätte ich mir auch mal fakt auf einmal
richtig um die stelle hinter mir heftig
angst vor einfach ich weiß nicht was da
ist aber ich mache auch immer einfach
alles zu weist also alle ausgänge die
ich irgendwie auch mal weil ich meine
grenzen sind kein nein ihr kommt niemand
rein
ja du bist nun grad
ich bin ganz und nicht weiß selbst wo
ich bin wenn ich allerdings nicht ich
habe richtig angst wenn du nicht mehr da
bist so süß von dir doch haben wir
nichts mehr zu essen ich habe noch 17
fleisch ja selbst ein gebratenes fleisch
17 gebauten fleisch ich habe einst jeder
siehst du auch mal wie das hier
aufgeteilt ist
so von der nahrungskette und so genoss
kette ja richtig biologieunterricht soll
ich uns jetzt einfach mal auf dem portal
machen oder machen wir das in unserer
nächsten basis das kann ja wie ach nee
du dass du darfst ja kein portal machen
hab ich eingesetzt
du darfst kein portal machen warum sagst
du mir das nachdem ich zwölf obsidian
abgefeiert habe ich ja stimmt das war
auch deswegen hast du irgendwas und
wegen höhe gelabert und so ein zeug nee
wir dürfen nicht das einzige benutzbare
portal das ist eine super jetzt einmal
frühjahr ist conny also wenn es stark
auf jeden fall mir das zu sagen nachdem
ich dann die ganze aktion abgesagt als
natürlich super aber doch ich kann jetzt
super sauber hält und ja aber nur zwei
ich habe 12 wir brauchen drei dann haben
wir es dann griff er insgesamt können
wir vieles super da brauchen wir die
ganzen jahr wandten
das ist gar keine verschwendung dann
verkaufen ich habe ich habe jetzt uns
fehlt ist ein jammer nur nicht findet
keinen mehr das ist echt nicht sogar ich
komme jetzt du dir der falls du denkst
dass da kommt das bin ich
ich weiß auch gar nicht wo ich bin ist
es ja was sind das hier da hast du dich
daran gebaut in die höhle oder naja ich
habe irgendwo von mir sind da auch wege
nee nee jetzt müssen wir da das dein
name ich sie deinen namen
ich sehe einen namen in der ferne wo
bist du ja öfter schlecht estate steht
aber auch herrn warst ja wir müssen wir
uns noch mal die us finden also bisher
ist es ja auch so dass deine diamanten
rate echte ganz schön zu wünschen übrig
ist ich ertappe schon ich höre wasser
ich habe dafür schon das ganze jahr
abgeräumt hat eine supertolle baum
farben gemacht die bahn ist einfach
spitze die läuft auch wie schmidts katze
jedoch müsse vom server herunter und
spaß 16 minuten
wir müssen trotzdem runter
man habe jetzt auch noch so war die wahl
war der moment ok jetzt ist ihr jetzt
ist die spitze gut dann band mir diese
folge ihre verbindung trennen und wir
hoffen euch gefallen wir müssen einen
diamanten auffinden lasst uns einfach
bewährt und gefallen wir wollen nicht
drüber kommen und schüler